hey here's a funny voice mail we hear
often from a guy I know as the san
antonio troll one of the traits of the
san antonio troll is that he calls in
and criticizes me for positions I
haven't taken and often criticizes my
coverage of stories I haven't even
talked about and here listen to what he
says about my view on reparations which
he clearly has never heard or doesn't
understand take a listen
so your interview with good ol sin hair
ruin about you ain't playing this
because these my statements is too good
oh and I'll never get laid yeah well two
things
first off I'm willing that you sit there
out of your little teeny little ivory
tower oh right the white man needs to
pay reparations blah blah got it
I've never said it but I'm willing to
bet that if you have to pay some of
those reparations let's say 30 points
from your paycheck um who think it
against any I'm running point it's
pretty sad that you far left this
constantly preach black power black
people you know this and that there's so
great yada yada yada yeah here you guys
are saying that black people can't make
it without white people's mind I think
it's very bad and I think it's racist
this is the best I've never said
anything even related black power this
is a program that bleaches preaches
black power who even makes cases around
reparations on the basis of whether
black people or quote so great so once
again someone criticizing me for a
position I've never taken and things
that I've never said as I've said before
as I said when I spoke to sam Harris as
I've said when people call in and ask me
about reparations I'm open to the idea
of reparations I have a number of
questions about the logistics of how it
would work I have a number of questions
about who it is that would receive them
and I'm willing to be convinced of
exactly how it would all work but I have
said that I believe strategically in
terms of the 2020 presidential campaign
it is a mistake to focus on reparations
and that is my position so criticize
that san antonio troll rather than
whatever cockamamie position you are
inherently implicitly suggests
I've taken because I just haven't and
I'm wondering if you even heard my
interview with with Sam Harris we've got
a great bonus show for you today get
instant access to the bonus show by
signing up at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show